uh who will go on for about 15 minutes
again then we'll do a group q a
uh so
yeah uh melanie without further ado uh
you have 15 minutes
great thank you can you hear me okay
[Music]
all right
well uh good afternoon everyone thanks
to all the prior speakers who've really
had some insightful talks and the
organizers for for pulling this together
and for allowing us to participate
remotely i know that's
sometimes a challenge i really
appreciate it
i'm going to start with
talking about my research which is not
directly related
so much to ai or humanity
by way of sort of offering a perspective
about
complexity and complex systems and and
how that might inform this discussion
so uh i work at the intersection the
multiple intersections of computation
and biology
uh we i've spent many years following
ants around in the desert to understand
how they forage
we build models of the immune system to
see how it responds to infection
um both of those examples of collective
search algorithms that have evolved in
nature
then we use those to build swarms of
robots sort of examples of collective or
swarm intelligence uh they're
bio-inspired so i'll give a couple words
about those i thought i'd start by
introducing this quote by brian arthur
economist who really founded the field
of complexity economics
which describes complex systems
economies particularly is one in which
agents or people explore try to make
sense react and re-react to the outcomes
they take they together create
so in other words it's complexity
emerging from repeated
adaptive iterative
interaction among the agents between the
agents in an environment and
i think most importantly
with the uh adaptations and
modifications that they've made to the
environment right so they create the
world they live in
um and then they and we
uh react to that world in different ways
so this slide kind of highlights some of
the
uh the work we've done in bio-inspired
robotics
uh this is me and my team out of the
desert new mexico watching how ants uh
ford is a little blue dyed ant foraging
for a pile of red seeds that we gave it
um and we wanted to ask the question how
do the collective rules
um
work
that enable ants to communicate with
each other
interact with an environment that might
have a few big dense piles like this and
a few more scattered piles
um ancillary pheromone trails to attract
each other to food
but the specific dynamics about when
those trails are reinforced to attract
new ants when they're deliberately
ignored all of those kinds of decisions
allow different colonies to adapt to
different environments
and so we
were able to sort of recapitulate the
way some of those foraging dynamics
worked
and then turn those into foraging rules
for swarms of robots
and
um
we've recently taken those robots into
the sky
so these are some of our aerial robots
that we
are now working on a volcano monitoring
project so we create flocks of these
robots that will sense uh gas emissions
from volcanoes and work with geologists
to be able to understand things about
the dynamics of carbon emission
from volcanic eruptions
and so all of these in some sense sort
of touch on ai right we have apply ai
and for example object recognition which
works a little differently in the real
world than it does
with computer generated images or even
computer images um real real objects
um
and um but but most of what i wanted to
really sort of highlight with this work
is that the interaction of agents
with each other uh generates some sort
of collective behavior that's very very
difficult to predict from the rules the
agents themselves use
the
in fact called the hard problem in swarm
engineering to figure out what are the
rules i want my individual agents to
follow if i want a collection of these
agents to achieve some certain goal
the other side of the work that we do is
in computational biology so this is
using essentially computer models
usually scaled up to large sizes
to uh to understand something about a
biological system so this is uh recent
work that we've done to model
uh the spread of the source code to
coronavirus in the lung
and so in this case what we did was
build a fractal branching model of the
lung so this is uh representing the
approximately half a trillion cells you
have in your lung
once we have that as a template
we can then import that into an
agent-based model
we look at real t cells and how they
move around these are t cells moving
around in the lung of a mouse
we can incorporate those movement
dynamics into the model
along with the viral dynamics to predict
how fast and what sort of spatial
distribution virus will spread in the
lungs
um and we can compare that to uh to real
ct images from real patients and kind of
re um do a decent job recapitulating the
dynamics of the virus and
the growth of tissue damage
in different patients under different
conditions
the big take-home message from that work
is that when we really consider these
spatial interactions how the virus
interacts with the physical template of
the lung and which cells are infectable
and how they're dispersed in space uh it
really matters how much virus you inhale
so wearing a mask is a really good idea
because if nothing else it keeps you
from inhaling large amounts of virus
which disperse uh through this fractal
branching networking alone
[Music]
uh so
this work is this is where we do our
real modeling work but where i think
it's relevant for this
discussion
i can get my slide to advance
is in thinking about the ways um that
what you might consider sort of the
low-level algorithm that controls the
virus how that actually has impact on
the world
um right so the the sars code two virus
it's got 30 000 base pairs maybe it's
maybe a relatively large genome for
virus but a very small amount of data
that controls its function
um
and
but what matters for how this virus
spreads and the incredible impact itself
in the world is really how it interacts
first at the level of human cells
right how it interacts for example with
t cells that are trying to kill it um
with uh different kinds of cells in the
lung which it's trying to infect
and then um at the level of the human
agent who's moving through space um
right who can breathe out these kinds of
aerosols that we used to think could
only go six feet but turns out can hang
around the rooms for long periods of
time
um and then those humans get on
uh you know transportation systems that
are built by our societies right that
allow this virus to travel in
unprecedented ways right no virus can
travel like this before among densely
populated individuals that that can span
the globe
and so um
the both the technologies that we've
built to communicate about this virus to
fight the virus to move ourselves around
all of these things have sort of created
this this ecosystem
um that the virus then responds to and
evolves in response to and so in some
ways some of the unprecedented
evolutionary changes in the virus are a
consequence not specifically of the
viral genome
um but it's evolving in response to the
human and societal patterns that it
actually
helped to create along with with human
behavioral responses and institutional
responses to its existence
and so i think that's an important
metaphor uh for understanding um
evolution and ai and complexity and ai
systems uh this is an example uh there's
a paper uh the surprising creativity of
digital evolution that joel layman led
um
that talks about these what are often
called perverse instantiations um in
evolutionary computation so so you
evolve some computer system to do
something
um and there are a number of reasons it
doesn't do what you want it to or what
you intended so right you misspecified
the fitness function um often it is
unintended
debugging your system for you because
you had bugs that weren't revealed until
your evolutionary system uh evolved
around those those constraints
um exceeded the expectations of whatever
you were designing and often these have
some convergence with some systems in
biology so the upper picture there is
showing a robot
which took advantage of some problems in
the physics simulator that it evolved in
and it's actually growing this long leg
essentially and turning it into a pull
itself into a pole vaulting machine
right and so it's it's goal was to move
quickly and instead of running as they
anticipated right the whole volts around
the world um in the simulated world
so there's a number of uh we heard
earlier
first talk i think about right these
examples where you essentially cheat
these video games right by finding these
strange corner cases
um lots of these examples where you're
you know exploiting evading leveraging
simulated physics in some cases or or
sort of errors in the problem
specification
one example that we
had early on in our research
these are our ian robots in this picture
in the lower corner
early uh examples of little robots that
were going around foraging for little
tags we left on the floor and they had
terrible localization error so the
robots are there's three robots you can
see there and three circles which are
indicating where the robots thought they
were they're always lost right they had
terrible um
localization capabilities and so when
these robots would communicate to other
robots and lay a little pheromone trail
saying hey when i found food over here
they would always mislead the other
robots to tell them to go to the wrong
place
but when we used an evolutionary system
to tune the parameters on how these
robots communicated what they actually
evolved was not to communicate at all so
when robots began to accidentally
mislead each other due to their
localization error they involve
strategies to stop talking to one
another um this is something that would
be fabulous if twitter could could come
up with one for us right so that when
people are being are misleading the the
swarm uh they would just be quiet
the um
so there are a number of different uh
examples of of where sort of the you
know unintended consequences are sort of
a natural result
of evolved systems and i would argue
that ai even an ai that's not explicitly
evolved
in order to interact usefully in complex
social environments it's going to need
to adapt to succeed so it's that
adaptation may may happen intrinsically
through some sort of evolutionary or
trial and error reinforcement learning
mechanism or may happen through human
tinkering
um and i think that this is sort of the
message that's sort of the work that
i've done sort of brings to this is that
these unintended consequences this
unpredictability that comes when you
have an adaptive process of technology
embedded in a larger complex system
is is what will lead to the
unpredictability which may be good and
may be bad
um
uh
and this sort of oops sorry about
technology
so um again this reiterates that point
that i think that the important impact
of ai depends not so much on particular
algorithms
but on the way that those algorithms
leverage and cause changes in human
behavior and institutional behavior
that are constantly reacting and
re-reacting
to this system that humanity and ai are
building together
an important perspective on this comes
from the more is different paper back
and it's now 50 years old um that really
talks about sort of as more and more
agents interact
you get something that is qualitatively
different
um so when we talk about you know large
language models that are learning based
on search patterns and
text responses from humans
who are using you know other algorithms
right and agents and ai to search right
this feedback of these systems i think
is actually going to create something
that's quite different than
any of the individual
agents that were created
so um i'll move on i just wanted to talk
about one example of sort of this idea
of repurposing
and um
this is a repurposed sort of and this is
ai this is repurposed very very simple
algorithm
uh this is the egfr equation this is an
estimate of kidney function
that is uh has been in the news actually
quite a bit recently but it's simple
regression equation that's relating
various proteins in the blood age
insects in order to estimate the kidney
function
and this equation um for a number of
decades has included a correction factor
of african-american race
that increases the kidney function score
by about 15
so you do everything else and then you
you say well you know you would have
poor kidney function but you're
african-american and so we're actually
going to say your kidney function is 15
better
and the result of this um
was delayed treat treatment at about a
million african-americans over these um
these decades
a number of many african-americans who
died awaiting kidney transplants because
their score was too high to get it
um
and the equation arose because of
assumptions about
um you know there's an empirical pattern
that african-americans have slightly
higher protein levels and an assumption
that this was due to higher muscle mass
a completely racist assumption that
actually not ever been uh
you know
validated in data
um but a sort of a biological race
assumption
that the algorithm you know exists
because of an assumption that that is
correct and reinforces um those false
beliefs
um there's actually a happy and in some
sense the story that there's a new race
neutral equation which is has recently
been adopted which is
a better predictor for everyone
but the repurposing
of this algorithm is a to me a
particularly fraught story so
um of course this score is used for all
sorts of medical purposes who's eligible
for chemotherapy because their kidneys
are sufficiently functional who's
eligible for certain kinds of drugs but
it was also used during the covid era
because they needed to identify
prisoners who were sick enough to be
released from prison during the
crisis
and so there were several cases of this
one in particular made the new york
times an african-american man
who had a particular kidney score that
would have qualified him to be released
from prison if he were white but in fact
he had to stay in prison he was the
judge decided he needed to stay in
prison because the equation with this
correction said his kidney was
functional enough and that he was not at
risk from coveted
um
and i think that this is not just a
problem for this this kind of an
equation right this is consistent with
all of the other covid prison release uh
bias that happened um where the the most
privileged least likely to be vulnerable
were actually disproportionately
released um over the the first two years
of the pandemic about 16
uh prison population drop occurred
um so although there are black men are
six times more likely to be in prison
the likelihood of being released due to
covered vulnerability was three times
higher for white prisoners
so um
in a sense you know this simple equation
sort of uh
sort of characterizes these kinds of
problems that we see for all sorts of
different reasons they tend to reinforce
you know the same sort of biases over
and over
so
uh i've begun working in this space i'm
obviously working in different kind in a
different sort of space in computational
biology
um but with chris moore who's pictured
here we gathered together an
interdisciplinary working group on
algorithmic justice so it's computer
scientists lawyers and social scientists
who have been working to demystify
algorithms for policy makers in new
mexico very specifically people working
criminal justice
pre-trial of attention very good
algorithms that determine whether or not
someone can be released without bail
really trying to understand the way the
transparency audibility and accuracy are
different in the legal profession than
they are in computation
understanding uh ways that algorithms
have
been involved in housing discrimination
disparate impact and in ways that
they're then actually deliberate through
political efforts
to chip away at some of the legal
frameworks and previous administration
that protected against these things
using specifically using algorithms
a bit later
i'll just i just have a last wrap-up
slide i just wanted to mention two
things um we held a workshop a few
months ago
where uh the title of which was can
algorithms bend the arc toward justice
and you know we had a really spirited
and
productive debate in which many people
thought that algorithms are actually not
tools that are capable of sort of moving
society in a better direction um they're
inherently tools
to preserve power and domination
there's a great quote that algorithms
are just simply pointing us in the wrong
direction of having us ask the wrong
kinds of questions they reify and
reinforce systemic racism stereotypes
and inequities
um and and sort of the idea that if
algorithms aren't specifically designed
to be part of the solution that they'll
simply reinforce
the problems
on the other hand we thought a lot about
the role of surveillance that is sort of
using algorithms and data to reflect
um the the bias and discrimination and
systems of power
ident as ways to sort of hold up a
mirror and identify and potentially
mitigate human bias
um and i think that uh you know there
are some tools
um that are out there there was a
comment made earlier about uh more
deliberative professions being a bit
better like lawyers and doctors being
better at understanding ai but the
lawyers that we have worked with have
been really afraid of the lack of
understanding of ai and algorithms and
and what these systems can and can't do
by policy makers and judges and
prosecutors um
and so i think there's a huge uh need to
to really sort of dig into these
questions
um with melanie mitchell we are uh
hoping to address some of this in an ai
research institute
and uh sort of one of the the big um
plans with that institute is to develop
a course in algorithmic justice um and
so this is uh
sonya rankin and kathy powers a law
faculty and political scientist at unm
um where we're hoping to design this
course um as i said i am new to this and
i would love to get input from from
folks here um this will be something
that we're going to try to make
available to the community through the
sfi complexity explorer online
platform
and um so i will leave this here and um
i think it's i'm a minute or two over so
we'll go to questions
thank you
thanks money uh okay i think we have
about 16 minutes uh for questions um
so i'll open it up to
the floor if anybody wants to raise your
hand for a question
can we somehow get both on the screen
oh
that is a good question um
is there a way to get both on the screen
right there
a quick question for the first speaker
you might want to hear no problem
um i just had a first question for
allison um a quick question um
i feel like people are kind of using
sentience cognition and intelligence
sort of interchangeably but those don't
seem to be like the same thing to me and
if you could just quickly or you know or
share your thoughts on that thanks
thanks yeah um so i think none of them
really apply to these cultural
technologies right so i agree with you i
think there's there's really different
arguments about whether a system is
intelligent whether it's sentient things
that are very simple could be sentient
like uh you know brunch ramp without
being terribly intelligent um i i think
it's a big mistake when we conflate
those different uh when we conflate
those different uh descriptions of
what's going on um
but i think
the point about the cultural
technologies is that they don't
none of those categories apply to them
so you wouldn't not only would you not
say that the library is
sentient but you wouldn't say that the
library was intelligent or that the
library
had new
oh you know it like if you if you said
who knows more you or the berkeley
library right that would just be a silly
question even though in some sense right
all the things there's many more pieces
of knowledge in the berkeley library
than you so i want to i want to do a bit
of the philosophical trick about just
saying it's a category mistake to think
about um
to think about cultural technologies as
if they're in the category of agents who
could be sentient or intelligent but
that's not to say that they're not
important because i think they're
absolutely crucial and crucially shape
human uh intelligence and human action
and including shaping it in lots of ways
that are really ethically uh that are
really ethically important so that's the
that's the claim that i'm making and and
i i you know i'm assuming everyone knows
the way the large language models work
but essentially the idea is that the
large language models really you know
are just extracting patterns from big
text databases um and that's of course
just very much like what a library does
or what uh what rating or print allow
you to do um like a library again you
wouldn't think of a card catalog as
being you wouldn't ask whether it was
sentient or intelligent but i think
that's a closer that's closer to what
something like a large language model is
doing
thanks uh let's take these two together
just to follow up so i understand that
you made a very good argument about like
the large language model is um
cultural technology
but there's also distinction because i
can embed or somebody can embed this
technology inside a human form
and give people the impression that it's
talking to a human which
the book cannot do that so i feel like
there might be also qualitative change
from
the previous print from culture
technology to this large language model
rather virtual reality all of that so
all this technology now can be embedded
in a human looking form
and that will get very different
impression for user yeah
again i mean maybe i'm just being
generally
skeptical but think about print from
that perspective if you read um jane
austen for instance who everyone loves
to read one of the points in jane austen
is that these young women in the 18th
century are going off and putting
themselves in a corner with novels and
thinking that the novels are real life
um they're writing letters to each other
and if you think about all the history
when of the time when the main way that
you interacted with people who were far
away was by by writing letters i think
you could make similar
uh you could make similar kinds of
arguments about the ways that people
took what were really
print
uh i mean that's what socrates is saying
that people are taking what's really
print what's really a book and treating
it as if it's
uh as if it's a message from a a message
from a real person and again i mean for
good and for ill that's that's
novels are really genuinely changing the
way that people novels letters are
really changing the way that people
think and interact so i mean of course
you know it could be that you could
uh it could be that you could put you
know put it put an ai in um
you know in a robot i'm not i mean you
can send someone a letter too i'm not
convinced that
that that's going to make a qualitative
um difference and you know the example
of misinformation is a nice uh it's an
interesting example where there's a
great deal of concern about
misinformation about things as there
should be about things like fake news or
fake videos but of course as soon as you
have writing as those french revolution
examples dave uh showed you have a
tremendous source of misinformation um
let's just like push back a little bit
like the the the large angry model we
have now is interactive you can ask
questions or come back but the books
cannot do
so
yeah
okay did you still wonder
hi uh thank you for two fantastic uh
contributions my question is also for
allison uh got nick so um when we talk
about large language models we talk
necessarily
about natural language interfaces right
so we also talk about uh prompt
engineering which is the term that
people have chosen to talk about the
design of inputs for these models um in
your talk you showed us a brief kind of
like quantitative bit right the
comparison uh with what children can do
versus what language models can do um so
i assume uh there is
please feel free to just tell me to go
read the paper but i assume there is you
know some prompt engineering you had to
do
to achieve those results at the same
time just recently there's been studies
that showed that um you can uh introduce
very specific keywords to make these
models behave uh better or to make them
be better at certain tasks like you can
tell gpd3 you know do this but very
carefully step by step and it will be
better at solving certain equations so
my question is in how far are these
models even testable and how far can you
take a hypothesis and verify it
vis-a-vis this specific model or any
large language model
yeah i mean i think the question is how
what what's going what happens with the
props and how much
uh
how much training do you have to do for
example to get the systems to start
producing uh start producing results
that look like what
that look like what humans are producing
but i think the the important point is
although they're interactive
what you're interacting with is
something that is summarizing what a
whole lot of other people have thought
or reacted to in the past um and that
that means that the
prompt engineering is going to be like
the kind of prompt i mean again this is
just an analogy and i'm i'm happy to be
to have pushback on this but if you
think about an index or
a catalog there are lots of situations
in which what we're doing is
doing something active that will pull
out some kinds of information rather
than others and indexes or catalogs can
be really different in terms of how
effective they are if you're thinking
about something like trying to search
through uh
search through the internet or search
through uh search through books um
uh so i think uh you know i think what's
we were actually a bit surprised and
there's interestingly there's a couple
of other results have come out at just
the same time that this causal task
which is not terribly hard right i mean
which is really simple four-year-olds
are doing it we didn't ask for computer
vision for it it's all symbolic it's we
gave we actually gave the systems the
language systems exactly the text in
fact more text than the kids had of the
descriptions of what was going what was
going on but i think it emphasizes the
fact that this this innovation is kind
of being able to go beyond the things
that other people have already told us
is so central to
uh to human intelligence that i'm
skeptical about whether you're going to
be able i mean that i'm sorry i'm going
on too much that dimension is going to
be the interesting dimension to look at
with large language modes and i want to
move ahead because i i see that there
are lots of other people raising their
hands let's do
deb and then helen
um i had a question for the second
speaker so you were sort of talking
about some of the risks associated with
repurposing the algorithms but there's
been a lot of
um recent work um
uh
on sort of how data sets are repurposed
and how
it's very common practice in machine
learning to reuse data sets and there's
certain harms associated with that
i think like denton it all kind of wrote
about this at the nerves data set and
benchmarks track last year um so yeah
i'm curious about your thoughts about
just the the differences in the risks
associated with repurposing data sets
versus the risks associated with
repurposing
algorithms and models
um and if you see those differently and
if you guys are talking about the former
as well because it seems to be a lot
more common in the field
yeah thank you that's a great question
um in some ways i think it's the same
problem although it's manifest in
different ways right i mean in some
sense some of the problems with
repurposing algorithms is that they're
they're based on data that themselves
have some sort of bias right and this is
in some sense the problem with language
models right the language that's there
reflects you know
some version of people's assumptions
about reality right um so we've all seen
lots of examples about
you know
refusing to to default to male nurses
and female doctors and things like that
um so i think that you know in some
sense they're these are entangled
problems that we we can't
they're both going to operate together
um the distinction between the
the data and the algorithm
is important for people who work on data
and data curation and trying to de-bias
data
versus those who are trying to
verify and audit and make transparent
the ways that algorithms use those data
so from a technological perspective i
think that the station can be important
um but in terms of sort of the impact of
these kinds of systems on humanity i i
think it's
you know to to the to the prisoner who's
trying to get out of jail it to some
extent doesn't matter is it the data or
the algorithm
right that's unfairly gotten
have you convicted those sorts of
questions
um
the
i think one thing um
that's perhaps somewhat unique to
algorithms some of the work that we did
challenging the disparate impact rules
on on housing so we've written just
public comment when the previous
administration
attempted to
design a rule um right now the fair
housing act says that um you can't make
lending decisions that have disparate
impact even if there's no racist intent
right you can't essentially
make decisions that redline and keep
certain racial groups out of certain
neighborhoods
um and the attempt was made to say that
well actually
if a bank is using an algorithm to make
this decision um you have to be able to
point to the line of code in which the
disparate impact occurs well that's
ridiculous right it's not a single line
of code right it's really the
interaction between
you know whatever algorithm which may or
may not be you know
available for people to audit
but the algorithm and the underlying
data um and that data may reflect you
know reality that is in fact sort of
perpetuated from historical
injustices or you know certain biased
data sets
right all of those they've kind of come
together to end up in the decision so i
think it's important to to sort of
begin to understand the ways in which
both data and algorithms can really
interact
and in making these really important
decisions that affect people's lives and
finances and freedom
okay thanks we'll do helen
yeah hi this is thank you so much to
both of you
and this is um a question for melanie
actually it's
i feel like there was a part of the talk
that i was
trying to
grasp and wasn't able to so this is kind
of an elementary please help me a little
bit here which is
this idea of um
the
um
the problem of repub unintended
consequences
consequences of repurposed
ai
and i
you know fast forward to the end of the
talk maybe because i'm just
um more familiar with some of these
cases and um i kind of could could
grasp those but i would love you to just
choose one of your other the earlier
cases
and explain a little bit um
just
if you don't mind just take me through a
little bit the reasoning of how this is
an instance of what you're
concerned about
yeah so i think thank you for the
question um i realized i tried to cram
so much in
so uh i
i think that the the point that i was
trying to make uh you know with the
kidney example uh that someone created
an algorithm right for a medical purpose
rather than and it made predictions
under making a certain set of
assumptions and
um the predictions have a meaning in a
certain context
and um in a biomedical context that
probably all um is consistent and at
least makes some sense even if there are
errors in it um when that algorithm then
is sort of repurposed to say oh well
we're going to use this sort of health
outcome to make predictions about who's
healthy enough you know right to be
released or not released
because sicker patients should be
released under this covid protocol
the idea there is that now the algorithm
has societal level consequences that you
know the doctors making this kidney
prediction sort of didn't
have on their radar
um
it's in some sense inherent to the
algorithm wherever it's it's applied
in that there was this underlying now
debunked sort of theory of of
racial differences in in muscle mass
that actually was underlying the reason
that african americans were specifically
highlighted and had this different
kidney score but the impact of that
um is not just medical right it then
falls into this
societal domain
um where it actually is part of you know
the exacerbated
and the differential uh imprisonment of
african americans right it's a tiny
little it's you know it's an
intestinally small slice of that
particular kind of bias but i guess i
was trying to get at the fact that these
algorithms um give this illusion of
objectivity that because it's a
mathematical formula that gives you a
number it can be taken from one context
and used in another
um and i think that's quite that's very
similar to the ways we use proxies for
example
um some of the work that we've done uh
that you're probably somewhat familiar
with uh the arnold's tool which is uh
one of his prisoner release
or prisoner risk assessment tools right
it's an open tool it's very simple you
put in data uh that are and it makes a
prediction about the likelihood that uh
uh someone will appear for their trial
and
in that sense it's it's a repurposing
of data the tool was trained on data
from kentucky but it's now used in
states all over the country and we did
some analysis that said you know what it
actually has differential impact among
different racial groups in different
states
right so it may underestimate or
overestimate you know
hispanic versus black versus
white uh prisoners in kentucky versus
new mexico
in that case it's sort of a repurposing
of the algorithm assuming that the
underlying patterns
which were predictive in one place
hold and are predictive in another
so i think that's a different version of
you know repurposing the algorithm just
by by applying it to a new population
and to me that's sort of the danger um
sort of this this idea that when you
have an algorithm whether it's you know
fancy ai
something that gives you something
that's purported to be a
an objective number but in fact is is
really laden with the context of the
problem you started with
um that you'll get
unintended consequences and that those
amplify because those consequences are
embedded in a criminal justice system or
a financial system
that already has
biases
hi um thank you very much to the two
speakers my question is for melanie as
well
uh i like the the phrase that you had up
on your
um slide that was uh the algorithm is
pointing in the wrong direction
um
and i wanted to ask what it would mean
to put the algorithm to work in the
direct in the other direction or the
direction that you think it should be
facing um and i'm thinking about this
through the work of a scholar like wendy
chun
um
uh where she's using say the example of
amazon's
uh hiring tool that um you know
disproportionately downgraded um
women uh when it was assessing like who
should get hired here and it was like
you know if you went to a historically
women's college then you were downgraded
if you just had the word woman in your
cv and it was like downgraded like
women's chess champion or something
right um and she was ex and for her
she's like uh they should be put to work
not in a role that is in prediction
around what happens next but
they're most useful in telling us what
happened before
so we could perhaps use an algorithm as
say you know a material witness to
provide evidence of discrimination that
we previously had not had the evidence
to do so so it was sort of um
the the outcome of that like we can like
it was a horrible thing and it showed us
sort of something that we didn't want to
see and it's forms of injustice and
discrimination that we didn't want to
see but it actually was incredibly
useful because it finally provided
evidence for so many of us who say have
only felt that discrimination um sort of
broadly and have never had the means to
prove it and here we have something that
can help us prove it um so that's one
question i had for you and the second
was actually more around the proxies and
i wanted to ask if you could just
talk more about
how
race is proxified within you know the
movement from repurposing from one
context to another thank you very much
great we'll take this one as well
okay
thank you um thank you both um my
question is for alison and it's just um
maybe this is something that i should
just read in in your work and i'm really
curious to to read that but i i guess um
i just wondering if you have a sense in
which um
the changing media
environment um has to be analytically
parsed right and i guess this kind of
comes to the conversation you were
having earlier i suppose i'm just
thinking about the way in which
different media take on different roles
in terms of authority and also the way
that they collapse time and coupled
together time in different ways and i
think those two things are interestingly
connected like
the way that in a pre-written
sorry a pre-print written culture books
were incredibly sacred and they were the
authority but they were also very slow
to make and to read and with print that
authority is undone because suddenly
everybody can read multiple books and
get multiple possible selections but
again they have time to read and to
think through and you can see the
working
and with the book you can always stop
reading and you can walk away which you
can't really do if you're talking to
socrates so
it seems
that particular idea of time
maybe one of the things about llm models
as a medium is that they collapse time
and they are opaque and they're working
and that might i just i'm just curious
in your in your research with um
with children you know i mean
are they sort of getting faster
are they
developing heuristics for responding
to this system that kind of demands a
response before there's any time to
really understand what's happened and
that's something i think about a lot in
relation to the authority of media i
guess
yeah
i think that's
sorry i mean like why do you
go
uh
there was something i wanted to mention
and actually in relation to the question
that was asked melanie which is i think
this and this is related to time as well
i think it's a really important
interesting point that
what these cultural technologies do is
summarize the past and not predict the
future that's exactly the difference
between imitation and innovation is that
when you even you know even a marvelous
library tells you what everybody's
thought and found before it doesn't tell
you doesn't give you a sense of what the
space and possibility is for the future
and and ethics is all about the space of
possibility for the future that's that's
how we make our ethical decisions are
all about what do we do next you know
what are the what's the space of
potential possibilities and i think that
it's very important to convey that for
something like a large language model
that might give the illusion of
enabling you to say something about the
future whereas what it's really doing is
just telling you something about uh
telling you something about what
happened in the past and then you take
that information and then you can decide
what the space of possibilities for the
future is like but sorry melanie
thanks that's a really that's a that's a
great way to put that um
so quickly i guess uh the point about
the algorithms pointed in the wrong
directions was actually a really
fascinating heated debate um very
productive that we had during our
workshop that you know uh the amazon
example is one that i use a lot uh but
certainly some good came from that right
of algorithms that could really document
these are the past practices the bias
that's already existed and and and
the algorithm can make that clear right
in that case you know the ai
the point that um the sort of
counterpoint to that is well but amazon
owned that right amazon made the
decision to reveal that that was what
was going on and that was that was a
good helpful thing but they didn't have
to
um and i think that the fear is that if
uh
the other example that's often pointed
to is very helpful is police body cams
right so that's data
that's that should be reflecting you
know the actions that sort of are
powerful
and um certainly algorithms could be
used to to
to glean something from that data but
the police sort of control the data
right they and we've just seen this in a
valley right right whether whether the
video is released is and when it is
released and that sort of thing is still
in the hands of the powerful and so i
think the concern
is that even though these tools can be
sort of turned
um to provide a mirror um to reflect
what's going on and allow us to react to
it um who has the power to determine to
decide when that that information is
released who gets to see it those sorts
of things
um so i think that the key
sort of
concern and i'm not sure that it's
you know how much it is the dominant
concern the key concern is that uh these
are tools that really will still be you
know tools of the powerful that will
still in some sense control those with
with less power
um and so that's sort of the perspective
of a lot of the political scientists or
the civil rights
activists who were involved in this in
this workshop
um
uh that's not to say that they aren't
useful in many cases
um
in terms of proxies i think that you
know in some cases some proxies are not
allowed
um
but there are always sort of racial
proxies that that lurk so for example in
prison release some of the racial
proxies
are things like you know putting
together a rest record of yourself your
family your juvenile record all of these
things that tend to uh accumulate in
some communities more than others
um
those sorts of
so that you know any of these tools that
gather a huge amount of data almost
certainly um
you can identify race without asking
what someone's race is right so even if
algorithms are not allowed to to use
race to predict
um you know likelihood to recommit a
crime all of these other factors are
highly correlated with race
um and in fact then we can sort of
perpetuate that bias
so i think that in some sense you know
the algorithms aren't the problem the
problem is the underlying data
and the underlying sort of uh structure
of society that the algorithms refine
and re-reinforce in some cases
and um you know even if the data are
accurate reflections of what happens in
society
i think that the fear is that algorithms
just take that data and and and actually
do we do in fact use them to predict the
future from the past
even though that isn't sort of
um
you know fair use of
reporting on what the past has been
okay thank you oh sorry uh i guess we
we're pretty much out of time allison
did you have a brief response yeah maybe
this is a good summary with both melanie
and and my response which is i don't
want it at all to suggest that this is
somehow you know discounting the
problems with uh with using of these new
systems i think the history is that and
this is also relevant to the question
that was just asked about time i think
each time that you have a new technology
and in particular each time you have a
new version of a cultural technology
it's going to raise new possibilities
for harm that you would not have
anticipated beforehand so you know the
possibilities for harm for books are
different from pamphlets are different
from
uh are different from
television are different from internet
are different from large language models
and what you have to do is pay attention
to here's the here's what's happening
with this
technology here's what we knew from the
past here's how it's allowing us
or misleading us about our access to
past information and then
start this process of which again is
sort of the whole point of the
innovation start this process of
innovating new techniques both within
and outside of the systems themselves
that can uh that can can have this kind
of ratcheting effect that seems to be
part of cultural uh cultural evolution
as well there's no guarantee that it
won't end up incredibly badly i mean it
could end up incredibly badly um but
there's also no guarantee that it's
gonna there's no guarantee that it will
end up incredibly badly and and
some this process of of producing new
norms new institutions seems to be the
way to go forward with it
okay thank you uh we'll stop it there so
let's thank our speakers again
alistair melanie
uh this concludes our regularly
scheduled programming uh for today we do
have uh would you like to say anything
helen about about the plans for tonight
or tomorrow um well the speakers uh
[Music]
um and see you back here tomorrow
yeah there's nothing else to say
yes
just to thank everyone who's been
sitting in the room and
contributing great ideas and just
creating
i know the sun is not here but
in my view more than the sun of the past
okay i guess
thank you